A few years ago, a new kind of pop star burst onto the music scene in Japan.
They're called Vocaloids, and they're basically singers made out of software.
Vocaloids aren't human at all.
They're crowdsourced creations made by their fans who use special music programs...
...to write songs in a synthetic voice...
...and perform them using animated avatars or holograms.
The most famous Vocaloid, Hatsune Miku, has become a national celebrity in Japan...
...with sold-out concerts and millions of dollars in merchandise sales.
Some Vocaloid fans are trying to bring the phenomenon to the US,...
...but can Americans be charmed by synthetic pop stars?